this is much bigger than about
persecuting an innocent man like
President Trump this is about trying to
take down the United States of America
and damage our country
um past the point of no return and and
that's what's really troubling here if
they can do this to president Trump on a
total sham bogus charge that there's no
crime he's completely innocent of in the
first place but it's besides past the
statute of limitations a state can't
bring a federal charge and it's total
it's total lawlessness but if they can
do that to him they can do that to
anyone and so that's the real troubling
thing here but I think ultimately this
will Mark a historic day when America
does begin its Resurgence as the
greatest nation on Earth because people
are waking up they're seeing the
corruption and they're not going to
stand for it anymore they're galvanizing
for the truth for justice Equal justice
under the law and that will ultimately
win in this case and over all for the
country right and there is another way
of looking at it which is that Donald
Trump is the first American president or
former president to be treated as a
criminal to be charged with a crime and
that is pretty humiliating
well that's what they do in third world
countries and it is humiliating for the
United States once the greatest nation
on Earth to be acting like a
run-of-the-mill dictatorship to be
acting like the Soviet Union of the same
people who screamed for seven years now
about Russia Russia Russia while they've
been behind the scenes turning us
transforming us into the Soviet Union
this is a show trial that's exactly what
this is isn't isn't a run-of-the-mill
dictatorship isn't that rather when
someone doesn't accept the result of an
election in the way that Donald Trump
still talking about Hillary Clinton well
hang on a minute Donald Trump still
hasn't accepted the result of the 2020
election now that is the sort of thing
that happens in dictatorships
no what the thing that happens in
dictatorships and like the Soviet Union
or like Iraq with Saddam Hussein getting
a hundred percent of the vote that they
have those are the Hallmarks of rigged
and fraudulent elections and when States
change their uh laws without going
through the state legislatures and do
completely arbitrary rules using covid
as an excuse to stuff The Ballot Box and
use mail-in voting which has been banned
in France since 1975. that is a lawless
election and president Trump will never
stop talking about it and the American
people know it in fact 32 percent of
Democrats believe that cheating affected
the 2020 election so the American people
know he's not going to stop speaking the
truth about it but if contesting the
results of an election was a crime
Hillary Clinton would be in jail the
Democrats would be in jail that's what
they do uh they've done for decades and
so it's completely ridiculous to try to
criminalize president Trump's Free
Speech Wisconsin institutional rights to
contest a very fraudulent election which
is all he ever did after 2020. but uh I
mean Donald Trump is being investigated
for trying to influence
um the election the election in Georgia
I mean that's just one other
investigation that's going on but that
was an attempt to influence the election
in Georgia no actually the attempt to
influence the election is happening
right now in New York in Georgia in D.C
this is election interference that why
would they need to go after the number
uh Donald J Trump uh if he wasn't
leading in the polls they wouldn't and
this is why they're doing it so this is
your election interference all president
Trump ever did was wanted free and fair
votes to count only legitimate votes to
count not ones that are recorded on
camera being stuffed in The Ballot Box
which we have mountains of evidence of
in Georgia and many other states so the
truth is going to ultimately Prevail
here president Trump is going to
continue to fight that but it's clearly
obvious that they wouldn't be going
after him uh if he wasn't right if he
wasn't leaving in all the polls and if
he wasn't going to win yet again in
2024. and another reality is that he's
also being investigated over instigating
uh violence at Capitol Hill of inflaming
the crowds he may face more charges for
that inciting Insurrection many people
would say a more serious charge that is
you know undermining American democracy
well I know you don't have the First
Amendment over there sadly but we do
have it in this country still and what
president Trump
urged Americans to do on that day was to
go peacefully and patriotically let your
voices be heard and there's probably
over a million people that day a very
peaceful crowd and so what president
Trump always urged was for people to be
peaceful and we know we've had countless
numbers of Maga rallies we just had one
in Waco Texas it's Gatherings of tens of
thousands of people they're always
peaceful and so there are investigations
going on about who was instigating that
violence but it certainly wasn't
president Trump which one of the
investigations are you most worried
about
we're not worried about any of them
because president Trump's completely
innocent I mean president Trump has
withstood seven years now of false
mayor's attacks they spied on his
campaign they tried to frame him for
collusion with Russia when it was
actually Hillary and the Democrats and
they've tried everything in the book and
now they're rewriting the book They're
rewriting crimes inventing them out of
thin air first in New York and I'm sure
they're pursuing them in other places
taxpayer funded by the way election
interference but we're not worried
because president Trump has always acted
in the bounds of law he's always taken
his oath to the Constitution very
seriously and the only reason they're
going after him is because he does take
it seriously because he represents the
American people and he fights for on
their behalf the corrupt ruling class
they cannot stand that because they're
getting rich on the demise of our
country they're opening our border
they're destroying our energy
Independence they're starting endless
Wars in Ukraine and they're getting rich
on top of it that is why they're so
afraid of him because he puts all of
that to an end when he gets back in the
white house isn't the problem here that
can you really have a man who doesn't
accept the result
uh in a democracy of the last election
can you really have that man stand in
the next election
of course you can because we have
someone who is fighting for the American
people if we don't have free and fair
elections we don't have a country and so
again I don't know why you're not asking
this question of Hillary Clinton uh of
plenty of Democrats who objected to the
Electoral College vote of Donald J Trump
I mean Jamie Raskin one of the you know
impeachment leaders for the Democrats
objected to president Trump's election
in 2017 it's completely absurd president
Trump followed the law he also followed
the facts and there's mountains of
evidence of election fraud there's more
and more coming out to this day and we
haven't fixed our elections it's
something that we're very keenly focused
on look no further than Arizona and that
Shaman of election in 2022. we need to
fix our elections and president Trump is
the man that's going to do it and that's
why they're so afraid of him as well
they don't want to let the American
people decide who rules them but where
is the evidence Where is the
but where is the evidence sorry to
interrupt you but where is the evidence
that the 2020 election was not fair
there was not free and fair where where
is it
why did Wisconsin ban drop boxes I after
the 2020 election finding them
unconstitutional those were added
outside the state legislature but where
is the court where is the court that is
determined that the election was unfair
they threw out cases for lack of
standing there are still pending cases
in Georgia of poll workers in Fulton
County who'd worked there for decades
and saw stacks of mail-in ballots with
no creases that were fraudulent votes
we're still waiting for that case to be
heard if you can believe it Mark all
these years later because they know the
truth and the law is not actually on
their side there's mountains of evidence
I mean two thousand mules just one
aspect of the cheating that went on with
stuffing it's on camera Mark it's on
camera well I just haven't said I
haven't heard the Court ruling anywhere
in the states that said it's unfair just
final Point
um you say that this could play well
politically for you some are arguing
that this is exactly what the Democrats
want that they want to take on uh Donald
Trump at the next election and if Donald
Trump is a convicted Criminal
so much the better for the Democrats
that's what some people are arguing I
think it's Preposterous it's
disinformation if they if they wanted to
face him they wouldn't have to try to
arrest him they'd let him win the
primary he's already winning he's
already going to win the primary uh and
clearly now his poll numbers are even
coming up because everything they do
backfires on them but they wouldn't have
to touch anything if they're if they're
so keen on facing him uh then get out of
the way then what but they're not there
that it's total lies it's just what they
said in 2016 as well they don't want to
face him because he's the leader of the
biggest political movement in American
history there are probably a hundred
million Americans that will support him
in 2024. that is not something that they
want to stand up against why does um why
do the polls show that most Americans
actually support 60 61 of Americans
actually support the indictment against
him which poll is that it was a poll
that was just on C CNN last night in CNN
we have very reliable source so you can
get a poll to say whatever you want
we've been polling this issue we've seen
it in the numbers Independence 70
percent know this is politically
motivated and you have to look no
further from what Alvin Bragg said he
said before he got into office that he
was going to go after Trump saying with
Leticia James same with all of these
corrupt prosecutors that is clear what
the agenda is the American people see
right through it and that's why his
support is rising and more and more
Americans are waking up just to how
corrupt this country has become okay Liz
Harrington appreciate your time thank
you very much thank you thank you very
much thank you very much